quick word of warning today's episode
contains a lot of
f-bombs and mf bombs
so
keep the kids away
[Music]
i don't often like to categorize my
friends this person is happens to be
this ethnicity this person is this
religion i just think of them as my
friends but for some reason last night
this came up and it occurred to me that
i i know and am friends with quite a few
lesbians i don't know how that happened
i'm very happy about it uh and so i was
kind of listing a lot of the friends
i've made over the years who happened to
be lesbians and um
christian grew silent for some reason i
instinctively got a little jealous so i
said
well i know lesbians too
defensive i got defensive and then you
said oh really like who
innocent and then i thought and then i
thought more and then i wracked my brain
pause and i was like i don't think i
have any lesbian friends well you
started getting paranoid that they don't
like me like you i know some of my
ex-girlfriends who have ended up
dabbling in lesbians that's right
lesbianism this is i'm guessing after
they dated you yeah right after that
that's a different podcast that's a
different intro life could be a dream
life could be a dream
hey everyone welcome to life is short
i'm your host justin long life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my brother
christian long hello christian zachary
long do you like that i don't love you
giving away what the z stands for oh
sorry christian zeelong giving away what
else could z stand for that
i used to say it's zeus zeus yes how
arrogant
well you think people well it would be
arrogant of my parents our parents yeah
yeah and also really i mean i hate to
say this misleading hey well no who
knows this is a podcast
um now i'm i'm racking my brain to think
of more lesbians i know uh but one more
thing that i would defend myself on you
and not only do you meet more people but
you went to a very liberal college
that's right very liberal school that's
right people were
out of the closet and it was accepted
because where we grew up christian i
grew up in in the suburbs of connecticut
it was quite a
you know sterile suburban
um and fairly conservative i would say i
don't think anybody was out of the
closet when i was in high school
so the reason we're talking about this
it's rather tangential but i think it's
i think it's there somewhere close
somewhere close other than justin long
and other friendo lesbians is larry
david and there's a very funny kirby
enthusiasm episode where it's all about
he loses favor with the lesbian
community and then he and he's
originally proud of his standing
and then then he loses favor with them
and then he wins them back at the end
and that of course is an episode that
we've seen so many times we're huge fans
of our guest today is an integral part
of that show um he is like the perfect
foil for larry david's comedic persona
so our guest is jb smoove who plays leon
black on curb and the thing with curb is
that the first five years was so
brilliant and i remember in season six
the first episode this storyline was
larry and cheryl were taking in this
family of people who had lost their home
from hurricane katrina yeah my first
thought was this feels a little gimmicky
and
not curb-like and i was afraid of
of them spoiling the chemistry that the
show had so brilliantly for five years
yeah so i remember being apprehensive
about it i remember thinking it's
potentially offensive too like yeah
you're gonna laugh at like a family from
new orleans yeah totally like everything
else on curb it was
brilliant but it also speaks to our
guest today and how brilliant he is yeah
that show went from being as good as it
was for five years and then he i think
took it to
another level i think he took it to a
higher level which
just that alone is such an
accomplishment it really is up there
with somebody coming on seinfeld or
somebody coming into a a comedic
environment that is already so
perfect established established and like
well oiled it's like the fact that he
came on and elevated that show
and had the confidence to do that to
step up to that plate um you're playing
with the best i had never met him and he
showed up with his wife shaw who's
really cool he was so fashionable he was
wearing these dark sunglasses he did
like the cool guy handshake with me that
i you know played obviously the beta
roll in
where he kind of a little spoon yeah he
just took me in and did that yeah
handshake hug thing which i
but you had met him
a couple times but you you ran into him
in an airport once yeah in london not
too long ago i was doing a job in london
and he was on a layover i guess from
italy i didn't know if he'd remember me
so i approached him kind of
gingerly because i i had met him so
briefly years ago on on the show ed he
he he did an episode of so i up i
approached him a little bit tentatively
and and he was like ah awesome it pulled
me in and did such a like cool and we it
just made me fill me with joy he's such
a present
uh
positive person he's like a force of
nature
like he's like a tornado yeah you know
and he he directs everything he just has
such presence yeah he's very we're very
different people he's i kind of need to
suss out the room and he he just goes
you're like a morning sprinkle yeah
you're like a dewy morning yeah
yeah like an overcast
morning a little bit of
he's like yeah he's a hurricane he's a
force um
we're going on about curb just because
that's such a
dear show to us but jb also we should
mention is a great stand-up he has been
performing for 20 30 years he's and he's
also just lived such an interesting life
he's done so many things i imagine he's
the kind of guy who does everything in
an entertaining way you know uh he if
he's working at starbucks he does so
with like gusto yeah and and uh and such
good good cheer he's very buoyant yes i
want to discover where
that comes from because it's something i
really admire and um gonna get into that
and many other things with the
incomparable jb smoove right after this
[Music]
[Music]
some communities have written jokes yeah
some of this says have premises
[ __ ] premise you go out there with a
premise it's always expanded uh-huh
because you use your ears just as much
as your mouth but but that's so that's
what you do on curb too you just kind of
expand on these
they get you get kernels you have like a
skeleton i have a skeleton i don't i
don't write the jokes out
let them become what they are going to
be in the moment
right so i might if i throw it out again
another time it'll be totally different
it'll be a different ending a different
setup
so when i did jerry's comedian cars
getting coffee yeah
you know while i'm in the moment every
scenario every word that comes out of
his mouth even just riding in the car
with an arm out the window triggers a
story triggers a line triggers a premise
none of that [ __ ] on curb is written at
all zero so there's an outline as far as
this the whole episode
but the dialogue is all empathy were you
is that intimidating that must be
intimidating no i [ __ ] love it i've
been working in that form for years
right just working in that form without
structure so you thrive i mean you drive
on everyone stand up i just
sometimes there's a skinny elephant in
the room uh-huh what is that what do you
mean what [ __ ] means that i'm a
skinny dude yeah and sometimes there's
an elephant in the room that you got to
address
yeah and that's improvised you supervise
that part if you ignore certain things
that everybody saw
everybody can see
like what's an example give me an
example you're on stage
some lady somebody walks by looking for
their seat uh-huh
[ __ ] started yeah you're walking back
you're just trying to
and you gotta
you gotta stop in the middle of that bit
yeah and say what the [ __ ] is wrong
grandma what's the [ __ ] now
you can't not ignore grandma right but
you have to you have to say
you know somebody
you got to address it yeah you got to
address that
this is certain things like when i do
shows i like my first 10 15 minutes to
be
of things about the city things that i
just saw something in the room that must
be why larry connects with you i mean
larry does a version of that too i mean
larry david does he observes
people might call it the minutia of life
yeah he's good at that he's very i mean
you both are i mean that's yeah he's
good he's good very good at that
i said this one thing all the time i
already used this as a metaphor
a character leon
he ain't wrong
he's just not right
that is a way of thinking that gives
those two characters the yin yang yes of
what it is even even in scenes
i gotta sit there like okay
there's something about
being on a tight rope with no net even
when you fall there's something to it oh
it's exciting it's like ouch i [ __ ]
fail oh god damn it
i found something out
in that fall i don't think you always
have to play the safe route with
everything yeah right well you certainly
don't with leon black on kirby but it
must help that larry seems so larry
david right both the character and the
persons they seem so tickled by you you
crack him up constantly
we are interesting together on camera
and
off camera for instance larry came to my
birthday party right uh-huh 300 people
[ __ ] amazing park what number
birthday was this 50. uh how was he at
apartment oh he's [ __ ] mad he's a
[ __ ] mess
in a good way he [ __ ] got the
earliest [ __ ] oh yeah he's [ __ ] like
people always ask me how was real larry
compared to larry on the show that's a
good question and of course the larry on
the show has turned the [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah but the real larry has his
little things uh his little quirks and
[ __ ] i have a birthday party i invited
live to the party now i'm gonna tell you
i didn't ever gonna [ __ ] show up for
larry showed the [ __ ] up to the party
about [ __ ] hour too early
he's [ __ ] walking around the [ __ ]
party i'm in my i'm in the hotel room
getting dressed i had my big party at
the sls hotel and i already called the
hotel room
yeah
where you at
that's where the [ __ ] are you at
i'm down here at your party walking
around
that's a larry
[ __ ] you know how early you are right
now for my party where are you at are
you coming down no
i'm gonna come on the party's phone so
larry why would i sit there
and wait for people to [ __ ] show up
at your party why would i sit there in
an empty ass room yeah you're the main
attraction one person at a time to show
the [ __ ] up
you don't get there before the opening
act no i said larry i gotta i gotta have
a grand entrance here
man my po this [ __ ] party was amazing
so what did he just wait down there by
himself he [ __ ] with his hands suit
jacket pulled back with his little hands
in his [ __ ] pocket some goddamn
sneakers
and corduroy pants i know his whole i
was whole [ __ ] yeah i know
he's very larry david
he's very [ __ ] like dude uh
blew his [ __ ] mind what did he say
about what was the difference between a
black party and a white party what's the
big deal
i had to let them know what goes down at
a black party
so what happened was you know i had
michael buffer do an intro what so
my wife and i man we were [ __ ] fresh
dressed
my party made the [ __ ] internet
google my party
we had custom-made outfits on it was a
classic man burlesque casino party oh
wow that old cars parked outside [ __ ]
man you
you're like gatsby i'm the great gatsby
the greater gadget the greater guest the
great greatest gatsby oh this [ __ ]
part is
amazing so i'm going to party i haven't
had a obama impersonate impersonator and
he did this whole obama thing
ah jb yeah big birthday to my good
friend jb smooth the smoothest smoothest
guy here here
in the world uh happy birthday buddy
have a great one buddy everybody
my wife and i we had our grand entrance
to the party theme music and everything
wow we walked through the party like the
king and queen and [ __ ] larry's is
telling me he's right behind me walking
with his hands in his pocket his [ __ ]
hands in his pocket
[ __ ] larry david sneakers and larry
davis shorts pants on that goddamn suit
i can pull back walking yeah you know
he's pissed off no he's pissed away that
he has a [ __ ] weight for me to come
downstairs to my own [ __ ] party hands
in his pocket
walking real slow
we walk on stage together larry walks on
stage right behind me on my tail
so i had my buddy hosting the party so i
had him he had me the microphone and
then i said i said what's up what's the
[ __ ] thing in the microphone
larry microphone oh my god
what's going on here we're both on stage
and now this [ __ ] turned into a straight
curb scene oh my god straight ass kirby
scene i'm going back and forth
argument about what took me so long to
come downstairs i said larry
who the [ __ ] comes to a party it's
[ __ ] early you're like two hours
early larry
this is a black party man
[ __ ] start late oh what's the difference
black white
who cares i said did you read the
background i said did you turn the flyer
over he said no i didn't turn the flight
over there you go on the back of the
flyer i said it's a [ __ ] black party
you get here when you [ __ ] get here
i didn't okay you're right i didn't read
the back of the flag
oh god but he had hit a great goddamn
time so when you meet larry david and
you know the show obviously and he said
is it an offer is it is it he's seen you
do something no i have this thing i do
when i'm acting as an actor and
auditions always walk into the room
as the character i didn't know that i
was going to improv directly directly
with that oh really this is my first
time do you know what the character is i
know who the character was yeah yeah and
i knew it was i knew by re i said oh i
know where this dude is i know and i
knew i knew the take i was going to give
him yeah i walk in the room as the
character so i don't got to turn that
[ __ ] off smart now you're going gonna
get a chance to see how the character is
upset yes how the character walks his
mannerisms how he walks in the room how
he turns the doorknob so you do that
with larry you just start improving you
gotta i do that anyway everywhere [ __ ]
that i do it all the time so when did
you know you got it just a long [ __ ]
story okay so yeah i realized i fired my
asian every [ __ ] body why [ __ ] wasn't
[ __ ] working yeah and i felt like i
was disappearing well you've been a
writer on ask now for three years yep
and this is like
my fourth season and i knew i wasn't
going to get renewed because i fired my
agent between me not being resigned and
me getting on curb
literally
a month and a half wow so
and that's the thing that
you know wow i left there
i come to la my wife had told me i was
going to be on curb that's the first
thing
because i was watching curve and i said
man i love this damn show so much i said
baby i would love to be on this show and
i remember she was washing dishes she
was like you know what you're going to
be on that show one day but you say
crazy stuff all the time i could see you
and larry together yeah and that was she
called that that's go that goes that
goes into the universe shot called it
yep so then my buddy i go on the road do
some stand up
find out my buddy passes away
i come to la for one day
and or i just met with a new agent
before i left new york to go on the road
i said well i'm in la i might as well
you know call my agent just say hi call
them they say you want to come in for a
minute and meet everybody for sure i
went in there
an agent comes in and said um i got an
audition if you want to go on it i said
what's it for it's a kirby enthusiast
weird i said oh [ __ ] that's amazing shy
i said [ __ ] i leave tomorrow morning i'm
gonna go right now i'll drive over there
i get to get to the audition there's
tons of people
waiting to go in there god the comedians
are new yeah boy friends i'm like oh
[ __ ] how weird is that you know i walk
in the room
i improvised with larry you started
laughing and i walked in the room ah you
know they even told me that they didn't
know who leon was so i walked in the
room that's cool which is cool yeah
that's tv magic i was this close to not
even coming to l.a
because i had to literally get off the
road change flights
and be able to go there for one day wow
and you've you've been in the character
shoes now you've worn those shoes for
how many years for like you know seven
eight eight years also i feel like
people think you're very like you are
likeable you have a likable persona
[ __ ] despite the fact that leon black
on curb does some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
he you know what he would think he would
know a lot but he just knows
the way he would handle it he's very
confident he's very confident even
though he's wearing the most [ __ ] up
outfit
you could ever imagine yeah when i'm in
a scene with larry i have to decide as
an actor what leon would do better to
decide whether i want to have larry's
back or going against him if he comes to
me with some crazy [ __ ] that just
happened to him oh that's not
established he doesn't say to you okay
no nothing nothing we don't know
anything
if i choose to go against him
i gotta have a valid
secure point i'm making a strong point
of view so many times we've done the
show larry said
what i gotta do with anything and now i
gotta explain what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with it she's so rich i love
the levels of yeah you got to have the
levels of improvise that means i'm
telling you how to handle this [ __ ] now
you're telling me what the [ __ ] does
this have to do with my problem now i
got to tell you what this has to do with
your [ __ ] problems yeah and i got to
get you back to your problem and and why
i just had something with your problem
but still get you back to your [ __ ]
problem and your voices and points of
views are so different yes but your your
end goal is the same which is like solve
the problem and it's and and your
comedic points of view
it's all based on truth i just got to
count like the the the blessings of
being able to uh be in the right place
the right time yeah but also
situate myself in these
team effort mindset yeah you know what i
mean i feel like i know you so much
better than i do because i barely know
you i can point directly to curb your
enthusiasm having seen that not only
seen the series but i go back and watch
it constantly i watch it in a way that
like it feels like hanging out with a
friend i saw you at an airport and i
hate running into people at airports
because i ah you're in transit you're
dealing with like you probably haven't
slept i was so happy to run into you we
ran each other into each other in that
airport i felt like we could have left
that airport right yeah brought some
like masks
and robbed the bank right put the masks
off yeah
it's a little cafe and [ __ ] have a
little latte if you're gonna rob a bank
and you've got to wear a president's
mask which president you go with do i go
with yeah [ __ ] you would think it would
be obama
but it wouldn't be yeah i would go
lincoln uh huh for some reason i think
you know why he's tall
long face like me a certain mask won't
fit my face
a president with a long ass face if i
got a mask on my [ __ ] chin is hanging
out the bottom of it
i'm gonna get caught i got this big ass
dimple too yeah that knows me and you
also can't talk
because you have an
you always when you on a layover in
another country you put your [ __ ]
mask on you still carry your carry-on
bag you bring your luggage with you
because after the robbery yeah pull the
mask over sit in the cafe have your
luggage sitting there like just two
tours everyone's got bags and you go
back to the airport check it again and
get on your [ __ ] flight and leave
that [ __ ] smart that's all i felt yeah
yeah when we ran into each other i could
have got away with some [ __ ]
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
i'm trying to imagine you as a kid you
were born in north carolina you moved to
mount vernon yeah i'll grow up in a
project man uh-huh let me tell you
something in mount vernon i'm already
and i'm tell you something man yeah [ __ ]
but we appreciate it what we [ __ ] had
and were you happy as a kid [ __ ] yeah
get in the morning or saturday morning
cartoons
or sunday sunday morning karate movies
what the [ __ ] else is there justin yeah
to life
you had friends
a thousand friends yeah
[ __ ] projects people on top of you
all right it's like a [ __ ] big ass
like a [ __ ] jenga it's like a big ass
jingle
yeah how do you how are you a loner in
the process people are living but
they're alone but people live in each
one of those blocks that's right
and no one's really pulling them out
it's like no you'll pull them out all
right [ __ ] yeah you know you put them
halfway out push it back in
in high school i was known you know i
wasn't a class clown i was a hallway
clown what's the difference between
classes yeah oh man it was on cracking
okay oh between classes man where you
make the rounds oh man took the long way
to class oh [ __ ] man so you loved making
people yeah i just love making people
laugh
and okay
really chased home all that [ __ ] really
oh i should chase the [ __ ] home what do
you what do you why what do you think
what do you attribute that to there's
always a weak person in class yeah on
average everybody has had a level in
their life where they got picked on and
yeah chased or beat up but once you have
one good fight and you win you're kind
of like and that's what happened to you
[ __ ] yeah i always i fought a lot i went
from kicking like doing like physical
fights to verbal fights
but how would these fights happen
because i i have a much more sanitized
upbringing i grew up in the suburbs kids
wouldn't really like and i'd always back
down from fights i didn't want to get my
hands dirty what is it like to no you
don't you only fight when you're
cornered you don't fight to fight
i only fought when i had no no choice
but to fight because in high school i
was the king they just call me houdini
i would disappear they say when they
hold their fist up and put their fist
over their eye and and their nose and
their other eye that means you're gonna
kick your ass out to school so you avoid
those bullies and you take a different
exit out of the school
and you gotta know all first thing i
tell people to do when you go to a new
school you walk around at school you
study the nuances of that school all the
exit doors uh-huh just in case some
[ __ ] go down you walk around that
school and you befriend the [ __ ]
janitor that [ __ ] knows all the
ways out of that [ __ ] he can tell you
all everything we befriend this dude
yeah he'll tell you that the bible tell
outside in front of the school how can i
get out of this building without them
seeing me by the way back then in high
school you were you were jerry angela
brooks sir angela brooks aka jerry
angelo also italiano got through
ancestry.com one day and find out
italiano where jerry angelo came from
i'm so curious now i'm on the bet that
it's a tight in my background i bet
daddy i know uh cc and i was over there
shooting uh a movie from spiderman
that's when i ran into because we ran
into each other in london you were in
italy every time i yes
i just want to pull up my my passport
let me say hey hey angelo welcome back
see
that means i've been there before uh-huh
maybe not just like where are you being
sure for another life another lifetime
and chatty welcome back to the angelo
hey everybody look look oh [ __ ]
hey you look a little different
you're just here
do you believe in other like past lives
do you think that's that yeah
of course yeah if you think there's not
a higher power
whatever you believe in the universe you
feel it when i say stuff i feel like i
said that [ __ ] before huh like in the
1930s i said that [ __ ] though uh-huh see
what i'm saying with a little like
bowler hat yeah whatever it is yeah do
you feel other people you you do you
feel relatives who are no longer here
yeah i got so many moments of
i can't explain it
like even when you talk about the curb
stuff
i can't explain how the universe works
but i know you prepare yourself for a
certain journey in your life
and
you know there's ways of recognizing
your journey like sometimes i i'll
ignore my journey i'll ignore little
things that happen because i want to
freak out hey like why can't you give me
something i can conjure people up by
writing partner miles he gets freaked
out by it so what do you say i don't
know how you do this
people we're driving to the airport we
start talking about football and also i
said yeah man i said this is amazing for
t.o that he's he's going into the hall
of fame
this is terrell owens for all of our
non-football fans part the car in the
airport get on the plane my buddy goes
i don't know how you do this
but look we just got on the [ __ ]
plane that's weird teo just walks on the
plane this happens constantly what do
you attribute that to what do you think
i don't know i think you i think you're
playing with the universe my whole
philosophy is
plant seeds
and be patient
and and allow those seeds to
grow and flourish so you plant seed
yeah yeah no matter what it is like the
first thing i did before i started doing
stand-up was i took an improv class at
the old improv comedy club in new york
city right after my class ended the club
closed down
so i took that improv that improv class
put down my toolbox and jb you're how
old at this point this is like early 20s
oh [ __ ] this is like
late 80s going into the 90s okay then i
started doing stand-up my stand-up act
was mostly improv
when i first started like playing around
with it i just was a fan of comedic
actors as far as stand-up comedians
richard pryor sure red fox bill cosby uh
george carlin yeah
george carlin as much of the fan i was
of everybody
george carlin was the one
that took me to the next plateau
i would rent his vhs tapes over and over
again
the video guy in the video story go like
damn man you've been doing this like 20
times as far as comedic actors god i
mean sellers oh yeah it's like gold to
me i just always love comedic actors all
these little pieces i think are things
that mold you into who you end up being
my brother and i were talking about the
idea of struggle how struggle is kind of
an asset for a lot of certainly for
entertainers did you ever reach a point
where you felt like i can't do this
anymore or it's too the struggle's too
much and i should just take the easier
route no
you you have to have confidence what you
do number one and you gotta know you can
always build a better a bigger better
house or a better mouth strap
if you're afraid to make a move yeah
you're never going to move that's the
one number one thing i think that helps
anybody in life is knowing your worth
and knowing what you can do well you're
going toe-to-toe with i in my opinion
the greatest comedic mind of our time
you go toe-to-toe with him and make that
guy laugh consistently my thing has
always been like i'm trying to make a
snot bubble about your nose oh that's is
that the ultimate that's what we that's
what we we you want to spit take you
want a genuine sauce
we want we want this stuff out of you
you don't want to be trying to make
somebody laugh you know that's always
the killer for improv right is to like
go looking for the job vince vance you
know him stay grounded pick your spot
play
[Music]
improv is not saying [ __ ] if you can
improvise your way as a real estate oh
yeah you [ __ ] sell a house that house
could be goofy as [ __ ] you mean
you sell it like it's the taj mahal you
can come in [ __ ] yeah you come in the
front door and trip over the toilet bowl
but you'll
you'll make that [ __ ] make sense yeah
what would you say as a realtor oh i i
just tripped what oh there's a toilet
bowl right when i walked through the
door you know how many times you've been
rushing home because the keys out yes
is how far the bathroom is from the
[ __ ] front door that is true so we
put this toilet bowl right in the
[ __ ] front door oh okay so it's right
there ready for you when you you're
never pissing yourself again
never
ever pissing yourself again that's a
good point good [ __ ] point that's
what i love about the show the bachelor
and i've talked about this way too much
but um the bachelor to me is a really
bad improv a friend of mine who used to
direct uh the show friday night lights
he said he was talking about how some
people are adept at improv and so just
can't do it and he described i said well
how would you articulate bad improv and
he said they play the subtext of the
scene so it's a lot of right now i'm
having such a good time with you and the
thing we just did was so fun and they're
just pointing out the obvious
yeah yeah they're trying to sell
themselves you're right we watch the
show so we [ __ ] love the show yeah
but we can pick out the guys that are
going home we could pick out the
[ __ ] oh yeah we have to become
masters of this [ __ ] you're watching
human nature all the little things yes
all she wants is about this dude right
here let's do it ain't good no she's not
gonna pick this dude you can tell he's
[ __ ] around right now he's just
coasting right now yeah but you do have
to know how to sell yourself without
selling yourself yes and you know the
guy who's succeeding right now it is
doing exactly what you're talking about
he is he's measured he's not forcing
anything he's not overselling and he's
just clearly like a sociopath that you
you have got to have that lane you also
gotta know what the [ __ ] is going on
with other other guys don't repeat [ __ ]
don't catch what they got you're
watching now with hannah hannah b yeah i
had to be watching that [ __ ]
you know what i hate when
people get on the show
and they act like they've never seen the
show yeah yeah that bugs that bugs be so
bad
wait a [ __ ] minute you act like
you've never seen this [ __ ] before you
know what it goes down you know the
routine right it's just been on 10 years
how you don't know what what this is it
bothers me that she's seeing other guys
and like
you know
you're one of 30 dudes oh you're one of
30 women but it's great because they all
become competitive all these guys and
then this season they all want to beat
each other that's the that's the thing i
don't like guys who get on the show and
instantly say
they're falling in love with the person
everybody says the same thing how about
this falling in love with you you know
what i can't stand out is how they all
jump up she jumps up on every one of
them now it used to be talk about yeah
we talk about this all the time it's
become wrong it's become the routine
yeah you run up you jump up and wrap
your legs around this dude there's
nothing behind it now it happens on
their second date and it happens out of
nowhere there's no chemistry there's no
connection wrapping legs around people
and then they peck each other a little
bit awkwardly it's weird i don't
understand i know well because because
they've all seen the show obviously and
and that's what happens on the show
eventually when they go maybe their
hometowns they're like i haven't seen
you in a couple days and they run up to
each other and then you jump and wrap
the legs around yeah
that's the thing i don't understand yeah
well i mean is that is there is there a
bad improvement of are there steps to
get to that point there should be
there should be there's zombies wrap
around now that's the second date the
second time they take the time they're
going on the one-on-one yeah and jump on
them and wrap the next round um
you had an amazing job at one point you
were a perfumer
what do you call that
perfume formulator some worldly stuff
yeah how did that happen your eyes are
perfect
these are things
that will mold you into the person yeah
that you're going to be for the rest of
your life but what how does somebody
become a producer my first after-school
job i was going for the wrestling team
uh-huh i had already put an application
in with my counselor so i'm going to i
want to have a school job
wanna buy me a car so i was in i was in
the wrestling room and my counselor
comes in the room says uh brooks a job
came through for you so i sat there like
damn
do i wanna wrestle these dudes
[Music]
or
or
don't want to buy my first car i'm going
to pull these tights off
let me get my ass back guys
let me at it you rip the singlet off
like macho man randy savage
yeah
that job was um let me tell you it was a
small perfumery which is a perfect place
for jerry angelo to be jerry angela
sounds like a perfume yeah
you want the ascent thank you
i know the boss was italian his name was
ray morata i wonder if he thought you
were italian that's maybe why he picked
me for the job what was that interview
like it wasn't even an interview to go
in there he showed me around
he needed someone at the school i walked
around with him he showed me all the
ropes had me packing boxes in the
beginning okay and then he had me
filling bottles with perfumes
then he had me helping him mix perfumes
really
i think right now with a few household
ingredients i could [ __ ] around and make
an amazing
cologne for you oh yeah i would love
that you must have a really refined
sense of smell then no no amazing
scissors oh yeah oh yeah man no i'm
telling you i work with lavender which
could be bad rosemary all these amazing
ingredients man really oh and and the
alcohol it must be 190 proof it's like
it was so like intense
so i would have to
put in these big big glass beakers
and no everything he would show me how
to weigh it
he would create it he would show me how
to how to make perfect did he was he um
grooming you to be his his kind of
protege perfumery um was to call it a uh
apprentice apprentice yes yes
i stayed i stayed there for a few years
and um i learned a lot what'd you learn
as a perfume perfume formulator
you know i learned
how to
measure
patience
let it breathe let things breathe again
you're kind you ha
that's again important for improv
you let it breathe yeah um yeah don't
rush things don't rest things man this
gob he was already 75 years old when i
started working there and all the
italian guys oh yeah
was he hurt when you said you wanted
that you had to leave for greener
pastures oh man oh yeah i i went to
college i graduated with school where'd
she go i went to uh first i did a
community college first i wanted to stay
home for a little while longer
and then uh
i graduated
studied uh engineering drafting and also
graphic design and did you did your
parents want you to go into something
like that something more practical like
engineering yeah
they know what we did what we did well
yeah i'm a big brother too so for me i
just wanna i always wanted to set an
example so i think education is
something you
you have under your belt as a thing
whether you're going to sports whether
you go into entertainment there's
nothing better than that base of knowing
a lot about something of course you know
it really it really pays off yeah i mean
we sit in calculus class like i'm not
gonna use this [ __ ]
ever well it's not that you're using the
the calculus formulas yeah you're using
the process
of building yeah yeah yeah and that's
everything everything has a formula for
sure it's not that you need to know that
you're gonna use this [ __ ] algebra
anywhere yeah you ain't pull that [ __ ]
out yet that's not the algebra it's the
formulations of putting into the process
the process of it is gonna take your ass
a long way so so you're there you're in
school and then and then at what point
when you're in sitting in these classes
are you daydreaming about becoming a
performer are you still daydreaming ass
yeah
but i'ma tell you i [ __ ] around in
eighth grade met like three or four
dudes who were just as fun as myself
uh-huh and got caught up in that [ __ ] i
had all these in the eighth grade uh-huh
two f's god how did you turn that around
i said to myself what the [ __ ] was i
doing
you know what i mean i was always a good
student no son
that [ __ ] hit the fan what did you think
about these
were you just preoccupied with
socializing with those guys we just
started playing too much uh-huh but the
thing about it was
my high school we had a eighth grade
school there was a separate eighth grade
school no yeah it was so what happened
was they got too crowded so they had
another
group of eighth graders that went to the
high school so they gave us our own
little area in the high school well just
eighth graders oh oh you can't put
eighth graders get our highest oh my god
we're still trying to figure out [ __ ] of
course man that's your biggest shock you
know just a bit so you were like a class
you that's what you said you were like
man we had so much damn fun i was on the
football team oh really oh man
oh why was superman we started having
fun i'm still friends with the same
dudes i grew up with really yes they
were at your 50th
yes oh that's cool amen what do they
think of your success how do they i
don't make what i do
important yeah you know i make i make
what i do something and a getaway
from things that are
taking over your brain
i don't i don't take it as
you know i don't see myself as you're
not saving the world yeah i'm i'm i'm
cool being
what i do yeah i'm doing what i do yeah
i don't need
well that's a very i like to be back i
just need to motivate people have you
motivate motivate you know the boys and
girls club kids yeah oh you still do
that yeah oh that's cool that's what's
my number one thing how did that start
i'm i was were you part of that program
i grew up
a boys and girls club kid oh wow i've
been involved with them
all my life really wow yeah i host all
the galas that's cool i do all the psas
how did that help you as a kid oh man it
was a place to go i just walked past the
boys and girls club to go home do my
homework come back out and go to the
club man long-lasting friends i still
got the same friends i grew up with did
that was part of the boys and girls club
wow
were your parents funny did they just
joke around a lot or did they recognize
my mom is the most hilarious person you
ever gonna meet uh-huh my mom is
hilarious what's your name elizabeth
whitehead what she's she calling ms
whitehead ms whitehead she's freaking
hilarious
hilarious you know and and you you get
these things you get certain things from
your parents your family you get little
things that that build your character
and build who you are what you get from
your dad do you think my dad was a hard
working this is a hard working guy
but i think i also learned things
i learned a little bit of both
you know i learned things that upset him
i learned things that he loved to do
what would upset him you know i think
when you work hard and you're trying to
provide for your family yeah i remember
one time this uh they hired this uh my
father at this lighting company for
years
i mean forever
and then
a younger guy came in
and he and he gave him a performance job
above my father
oh my father was heated man was a white
guy i was a regular white guy yeah he
quit he quit the job he said you know
what [ __ ] them really yeah you know you
know getting another job but he was
principal though i never and you know
what
i i don't think he actually ever
recovered from really just like being
slighted like uh
i think you put a lot of years into
something oh god i think i think you
have i think it
you
it's not worse than expecting something
yeah and you work hard and you put years
in
and all of a sudden you're not it's a
betrayal it's a betrayed yeah yeah
it's a betrayal so so he carried that
with him you think yeah i i i think i
think that happens
whether you own your own business
or whether you're working someplace and
it's it kind of did it's defeating it oh
yeah
it's demoralizing yeah it defeats you a
little bit when you're not
you know what you expect out of
something so when things and the work
you put into it and you want people to
respect your
character your hard work your work ethic
but you also want people to respect your
presence
yeah your presence sure because that's
your especially the presence is like
this certainly that's your purpose
you can't you can't get back immediately
yeah you know they already say you know
uh you're going to meet someone for the
first time once
all those things are true
you really are the whatever you give
that person the first time you meet them
that's who you are yes first impressions
are really that's first impression
that's who the [ __ ] you're supposed to
be when did you change your name to jb
smoove
i've always well iceberg a dancer i used
to dance for hip-hop groups and r b
groups oh what's up don't talk about
back in the day
yeah like you know um
my name was jay smoove he was like a fly
guy partner's name was j groove it was
groove and smooth oh
man
man you know how big daddy can you have
scrap and scoop of scrap i wish i did
you know big daddy i know big daddy kane
i know big daddy kane have i ever
sounded whiter i just can't hold back
and forth because i'm a man with soul in
effect so what the heck rock the disco
tech and this group is what's next just
in case people are confused that was jb
doing that it wasn't me
i call him large father kanenstein
his full name
[Laughter]
oh man you gotta realize i grew up in
the heyday of hip-hop yeah so when i
tell you
there's probably not a party
or or plateau in hip-hop that i was not
either there
or i wasn't carrying the records for the
guy who was djing that night really like
anything you could think of i was there
i've seen every
major plateau i see eddie murphy become
eddie murphy i send off senior hall
become a city of hall i see mike tyson
become champion i used to be at parties
dancing on the dance floor and see them
walking parties together like oh [ __ ]
the champ he's 18 year old mike tyson
welcome to the club
no [ __ ]
murphy with arsenio with whoever and
what stopped you as i can't imagine you
you restraining yourself from going up
to them and saying hey man i just wanna
no no no chill the [ __ ] out yeah they
ate the same party as you ah you once
you are in the same room as people
you are with them
life could be a dream
did you spend a lot of time thinking
about you you or any time thinking about
your legacy thinking about what's next
do you how you remembered i'm always
thinking about my body of work
you look where i started from
once you are afraid that you're gonna
fail yeah you probably are gonna fail
but if you're not afraid to learn from
your failures
or to learn from a decision you made
like sometimes i take weird chances on
[ __ ] yeah but
i stick to my guns on it and i've got to
live with it what are you afraid of are
you afraid of anything i think i'm
afraid i'm afraid of death
i'm not i'm more afraid of how people
who i love will feel yeah yeah as
opposed to myself i'm more that kind of
guy yeah you know what i mean that's
right when you throw the party you want
people to have fun let me tell you
something we had a wedding in our
backyard of our new house we moved here
from when i did snl
and i and i got the curb job we packed
our [ __ ] up in a penske truck and we
drove across country
right we drove across my wife myself and
our little dog that's cool and we drove
across country through three storms we
left on a 7 p.m on a thursday night got
here one in the afternoon on a sunday
the next day i had to be on set wow so
we don't [ __ ] around what's your dog's
name i got three dog lovely is our 15
year old advent pincher
and we just got two puppies named hustle
and flow
i should have guessed that
so you get out there one pim next day
you gotta work oh so i was saying was we
met this uh we meet people every day we
met a guy in a sushi restaurant
two dudes in a sushi restaurant
like a few days before our wedding and
they were so goddamn cool we invited
them to our got them to our wedding
[Laughter]
we just was in there at the sushi bar
every freaking avocado rolls and [ __ ]
[ __ ] over
hey try this one you're gonna love this
one my favorite role
hey we're the japanese guys no
i do
we ended up we ended up
inviting them to our wedding that's
hilarious
we're at the wedding giving our speech
at the wedding we're going to thank
everybody for coming out we got
so-and-so i haven't seen this guy in the
years we got hey give me a shout out to
my two friends met last week at the
sushi bar
people probably thought you were kidding
me
uh what what is years ago
do you still see him
yeah we're still seeing content oh
really that's really fun
so i i just have short ones quick ones
or they can be whatever how your
business man we are connecting souls
right now yeah
uh what is your most commonly used emoji
oh the heart emoji is my favorite yeah
and the um
is the one with the the blown the kiss
oh yeah yeah yeah and then the one with
the heart eyes okay all right
fire is fire oh yeah [ __ ] fire you'll
finish off uh
passion passion um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
football of course wide receiver
obviously
you're a chess fan but i also grew up
loving funny car racing oh funny car i
used to watch funny car racing for hours
you mean like go-kart
funny cars what's your dragsters
straight line okay quarter-mouth
you like to drive i love driving what do
you do i think i think oh man i'm old
school i don't have a new car okay i got
a 68 lincoln wow suicide doors i got a
uh a 2008 first edition
dodge challenger srt8
on the first run they only made 6500 wow
i also have a
2008
uh international mxt diesel truck
[ __ ] diesel [ __ ] real freight a
freight [ __ ] truck
yeah i have a similar car i have a 2005
prius toyota
yeah [ __ ] man's car so i get it
that's the first turn that's the first
turn in the in guy's economy yeah um and
i have a uh 2010
uh dodge ram uh one snack food for the
rest of your life oh snack food
guilty pleasure would you consider
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches or
snacks uh no how about peanut butter and
jelly on saltine crackers yeah more of a
small [ __ ] author so do you go like
racist
hors d'oeuvres that's my go-to if i run
out of bread yeah i always have a box of
sauteed crackers so i make little
a whole plate full of peanut butter and
jelly orders yeah
you are old school new school i'm old
school
what's your favorite movie of all time i
think you answered oh
see
uh top three oh my all time will be of
all time
anything peter sellers is always my
favorite being there no the party is one
of the party the party i also fell in
love with burt reynolds movies man oh
yeah you can abandon it i don't know
hilarious yeah and claudine is my
favorite favorite movie i don't know
that one what claudina i gotta check
man james earl jones diane carroll man
wow oh man [ __ ] amazing movie old
school name you want some soul yeah
watch that [ __ ] i do need i need soul
what's that [ __ ] that's my soul to that
[ __ ] claudine
harlem she's a single mother
james earl jones comes into our life oh
man [ __ ] amazing movie man i can fall
in love before all the love
yeah so [ __ ] amazing
claudine um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
those people that you can't approach
pedestals okay marvin gaye marvin gaye
senior no no no i'm kidding
yeah no no that's what they do
yeah um
sorry too soon and uh
maybe gandhi okay somebody with some
something something like a i could
throw my philosophy on yeah yeah i have
him doing this right here like ponder
that
[ __ ] yeah pulls his glasses off he's he
cleans his glasses on his robe you know
what i mean
why is his glasses on his roll put his
glasses back on you intrigued me i can't
do a guy i'm intrigued but you're
getting that ass statement i would love
to see that dinner [ __ ] who's your
favorite muppet are you into the muppets
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
um who do you identify with i love
kermit i'm a fozzie i like fossils
yeah both entertainers
yeah
well you like you think
so you like the thickness of her no i'm
just saying she's just
and she's
into that yeah but i think i think i
like uh
i like i like kermit man yeah yeah my
dude man yeah
um if you could have one superpower what
would it be
oh
i wanna be the fly okay but i don't
wanna be able to fly low i'm just good
at heights so i'm gonna fly but real low
um
load to the ground yeah like a paper
airplane yeah really no optimal really
though oh like like like one of those
cruisers and starters like waste hot
like that like hoverboard oh yeah okay
you know what i mean yeah yeah
but what
so you just want to be able to get to
different places faster no no a better
power is power persuasion yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] good too
what yeah i'm sure you use it why not
what non-human animal would you want to
be
who do you know people say he's my
spirit animal
who's would your spirit animal be you
know what i [ __ ] love
love giraffes
ah
i love them well you have an elongated a
very long and long and lean up here yeah
a very long lead and they just they're
up in the trees
[Music]
checking everything out they walk around
and [ __ ] yeah very prideful you'll see a
[ __ ] yeah giraffe walk around they
got pride they can't hang their heads
they would care for their necks they had
to they're
dogs are cats i know this answer dogs
all damn all day hustle and flow hustle
and [ __ ] flow lovely because of sexy
lovely i'm telling you my dog is online
google jb smooth and google lovely jb
smooth and lovely okay
yeah
she hosts she's been she's presented at
the world dog awards three times
i don't know what that means but the
world dog awards man's the famous award
show oh really they give awards to dogs
yes like
tv dogs they are they're oh that's true
commercial dogs that's true
dogs that save lives yeah that's they
honor all the dogs
and you present it three times so i'm
guessing you've been [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah lovely that's not
that they're on there i've been there
we've all my wife myself shaw we've been
to dogs in the dark of war three years
uh i i can't wait to google that uh
beetles stones stones all day really
quick little [ __ ] story yeah i'm in
craig's restaurant one of our favorite
restaurants we're sitting there having a
meal we we're sitting next to a table
behind us in the corner and we can hear
them talking and they're having a good
ass time and one lady taps me on the
shoulder she said oh my god
we love
you so much on kirby enthusiasm we work
for mick jagger
he
freaking
loves you to death i said what
mick jagger loves he said no he loves
you she's like mike jagger she said mix
jack mike jagger
mick jack and love
that's a [ __ ] honor i was like i said
i love mick jagger i said tommy give him
my love this was like a year or two ago
yeah he's on tour he's in ireland right
now he's performing a bunch of shows if
you show up he would [ __ ] lose his
marbles
i said i wish i could go but god damn it
i'm i'm working on a show right now
but man everybody has [ __ ] to do
you think i would have showed up on my
man mick jagger hey yeah big shout out
to my man mick jagger i appreciate the
love wait you two you did you
okay i was working i couldn't go but it
was just ironic that you broke up the
how crazy
or
the stone wow wow yo man mick jagger man
i can't wait to meet him amick if
he's hopefully listening hopefully i
know most of the stones he's back on his
feet too he was he had operations that's
right yeah it's amazing he's still doing
it i want to come on towards you man
we would love to come out to ireland or
wherever you are in the world man
my man
this would
oh yeah oh i bet he'd want to do it and
this is this is dark and i hate ending
on it oh no
epitaph what do you want your epitaph to
be or do you want to be buried do you
want to be
no i just
no i'm so fresh yeah also [ __ ] fresh
yeah i don't think i think i'm just
going to stand around chill out
is that cool please do [ __ ] why not i we
i it's better for the world if you do
that it's much better for the [ __ ]
world yeah um where are you where's your
next stand update
man my tour my lot of gagging tour so
far we've knocked out two already if you
follow me on instagram okay oh
snap
jb smooth that's what it is yeah oh snap
how many o's just always snap oh snap jb
smooth you know how many times i've
heard that
oh snapchat walk down new york street
yeah jb smooth all right hello jb all
right well fool
do you ever see uh white guys trying to
seem like hipper and like more kind of
cool around you
you know what do you ever get that sense
that they're like j what uh
people realize that we're all one thing
in this world man it's going to be so
fun hey can't wait
to see
the one the oneness of uh not just this
country but the oneness of the world i
know we're gonna hit this thing where
we're all gonna be so relatable to each
other yeah that there is no there's not
gonna be anything that that makes us
different well you you you have more
than done your part i think just
culturally but by being on a show like
curve that everyone black white is
everyone watches that [ __ ] it increases
your demographics and demographics have
exceeded
you know even on my tour you know i i
really love that so many different
people come out really people actually
fly into the country from ireland
ireland you know the stones could do
that i met people from ireland prague
wow london who fly into caroline that my
next date is caroline's in new york six
big shows they can find all the tour
dates on oh snap
snap
do a lot of people call you smooth do
they get it wrong
sometimes they'll do it yeah yeah yeah
they'll stay smooth do you correct that
right smooth
yeah but it's all good and the next
season occurred premieres i don't know
wait no that's right it's whenever he
wants right never let him want to
[ __ ] drop it i know we all done
shooting though oh you're done season
10.
which is a plateau oh yeah i first met
larry i told larry my first thing i said
i actually
how many seasons he was going to do
no i don't know
he didn't know
i said whatever you do man think about
how cool the box set it's gonna look
a certain amount of don't stop on a
weird goofy-ass number
yeah now we have 10. you don't make the
[ __ ] number well it's scary because
what if he stops at that you know but i
can see him stopping at like 11 or some
goofy number weird number [ __ ] then you
gotta explain why 13 and a half 13
[ __ ] half yeah which is not a bad
idea yeah like 13 and a half well
i can't wait yep then um of course we
got the amazing we got spider-man yeah
when is that that's from home far from
home it's july july 2nd oh that'll be
fun it'll be fun it's gonna be fun to
see take your family and be fine man we
got our red carpet coming we got our
premiere coming up uh you're gonna like
man you're gonna look smooth um let's
move as [ __ ] man yeah you look smooth
now like you come in where i i always
see you you look good you you you are
conscientious about very fashion yeah
you are very fast and conscious i should
point out that you're wearing sunglasses
right now god damn right i'm wearing
sunglasses
but i don't need to see your eyes i can
feel you and um it was it's been such i
feel you
look at us yeah look at us we're
communing i i can't thank you enough for
doing this thank you man thanks for
listening guys thank you guys we love
you
so
that [ __ ] happened so that happened
so that [ __ ] [ __ ] happened
oh my god is there anything better than
not only hearing that guy say words but
specifically [ __ ] i know he's so
he says in such a different way than me
because for you know what i think it is
for so many years we were not allowed to
say that word so even now during my like
formative years when i was like learning
language and developing like
communication skills i if i wanted to
say [ __ ] i would have to say it like
this i would have to say it like this
[ __ ] i remember that yeah i still you
still put a weird uh the vowel and it
sounds a little weird like [ __ ] yeah i
pull back yeah [ __ ] yeah it's just
subconscious i just in fact i remember
the first time i ever cursed out loud i
remember it i was on the playground in
third grade and where do you spend most
of your days yeah chilling out remax and
relaxing
shooting some b-ball um
in west fairfield connecticut
remember that playground behind
riverfield it was massive and so i went
away from everybody i made sure i was
like
way out of earshot from everyone else
and i just to myself i just went ass
that's so weird i know ass was god
wouldn't you love
the ability to go back and see
so badly
it seems like i can't believe i'm saying
this about myself but it seems like it
probably looked pretty funny and cute oh
my god yeah a little bulky if you don't
say so i know i know but i was like a
little i was like like a tiny kid
i guess i was cute
it's just weird that you said that i
know i bet it was cute i bet i was
adorable saying that
but for days after i was guilty but
you're right uh i felt guilt i remember
praying like i'm so sorry he seems like
he never had a problem with that because
he really owns it but when he's talking
about serious stuff he doesn't swear at
all like when he was talking about his
parents when he was talking about
interesting when his dad lost his job
when he was talking about more serious
things he didn't swear i thought it was
really interesting huh it's almost just
become so
part of his comedic persona that
um i wonder yeah maybe it's just a
coincidence oh the story of larry coming
to his birthday party is so funny yeah
because he paints the picture he's so
good at telling stories that he has i
also noticed this about him he has a
sort of conspiratorial tone about him
sometimes he's like here's the [ __ ]
thing i should do and he's very like yes
hush hush and it's like let me tell you
something and he says crazy [ __ ] well
that's his way of saying vince van is
this great line where he goes you know a
lot of people will say uh let me let me
paint the picture for you and vince's
line is
let me set the table
let me set the table larry walks in and
he that's how that's his way of setting
the table for everyone okay just make
sure you're listening to me yeah uh and
the story he tells about the robbing the
not it didn't happen obviously but
just picturing the two of you
wearing president's masks robbing a bank
is so funny and easy to picture yeah
because of the way it was set up you
know like that's such an absurd thing to
picture you two would never do that
together obviously but the way he set it
up i i had such a clear
image of that lincoln mask on his face
with his chin hanging down underneath it
and you behind him wearing like a
well like a calvin kuhler mask or
something something less uh uh what
president would i wear i was trying to
think that uh of um my mind went blank
i don't know what's a good presence a
more obscure one that no one would yeah
like pierce like chester arthur zachary
taylor millard fillmore oh yeah you'd
make a great miller fillmore thank you
it'll be a funny halloween costume you
should dress as some obscure president
and be really incredulous when someone
asks what you are a millard fillmore
president hello
uh james k polk anyone
he was the president of the united
states yeah isn't that crazy i mean
we've talked about this on the show
before but just in terms of legacy that
like
these people are
and now to us they're like
footnotes they're just names that like
most people don't know i know when you
were driving yesterday we saw wc fields
avenue or something and he was this
amazing legendary comedic performer and
now he's the biggest star in the world
oh huge massive and now he's just like a
little street in amazing in l.a he's a
driver i'm sure he's more more than that
to his family well yeah
he's also a field somewhere wc fields
field
he's a baseball diamond when he was
talking about his cars the car seat
drove yeah uh i could tell obviously
because i know you that you don't know
much about cars oh i was so out of here
i was naming each one he's like i have
the 1978 this and that i don't know
about cars dodge tracker
oh cool
i knew you didn't know anything he's
like yeah no no i also and then like
he got excited he really lit up about
cars i wish yeah i know
i know i don't know anything about uh he
here's where he differs from wolfgang
puck he
his snack is a snack choice of
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches on
saltines [ __ ]
saltines
saltines peanut butter made if you guys
didn't listen to the wolfgang puck
episode peanut butter makes him nauseous
just the smell of it it was one of the
few times wolfgang puck didn't seem at
all like positive or buoyant peanut
butter was brought up he seemed
disgusted by it
he he got this look about him like
i can't believe you even mentioned that
in my presence
i could listen to jb smoove say the word
in the words
peanut butter and jelly saltines
all yeah day i was so disappointed when
that kind of when the conversation ended
i was like no
i wanted more [ __ ] peanut
butter jelly on [ __ ] saltines
oh it's the best his dinner i thought
sounded incredible oh yeah who was in
his uh
junior
yeah thanks for specifying
peter sellers oh yeah yeah and gandhi
gandhi i love what he said about gandhi
how he was like i would want gandhi
there to like you know i would obviously
i'd want to like learn from him yes
share your wisdom
and instead he was like i wanna i wanna
share my wisdom with him because i wanna
throw my philosophy on him yes yes and
have him be like hmm
it's funny to think about gandhi and
wanting god to to be around gandhi just
so you can be like in your face gandhi
what's up what's up gandhi oh my god and
of all the funny
uh paintings he painted with his stories
in this show i think that the funniest
image
was
him flying but he's afraid of
heights oh yeah so him flying at a low
height
so picturing jb's so he pictured he
pictured them just like hovering around
is such a funny picture to me but just
to be a little bit above people just to
see what's going on well that's why
maybe he likes giraffes
yeah the same same mentality he's so
good at just in general those short
questions he's so good at answering
because he's just so quick i could see
him light up he got really excited by
some of them too i'm now picturing
you're right it's really funny to
picture jb's move
hovering
[Laughter]
oh god
jb on a segway would be really fun i
mean anyone on a segway is funny to a
picture
but he might be the funniest uh well i'm
gonna go google jb smoove dog and jb
smoove
birthday party you should all be doing
that right now what are you doing
listening to this um
so let's wrap this up so we can all
google that stuff and uh
thank you guys for listening this i hope
you had as much fun even half as much
fun as i did talking to jb smoove we'll
see you next week
thank you guys for listening to life is
short if you enjoyed the show leave us a
[ __ ] review we are reading all
of them we love hearing from you guys uh
they've been very helpful and tell your
friends to subscribe we're available on
apple podcasts spotify google podcast
and every major listening app as well as
wundery.com you could also support the
show by answering a survey on
wondery.com
survey life is short is hosted by me
justin long it's produced by christian
long and megan monaco michelle lanz is
our [ __ ] senior producer
executive produced by marshall louis and
hernan lopez for wondering and our theme
song is performed by our pal rmr
[Music]
what are dms
she slid into his dms what's dms direct
message
on instagram direct message you can
direct message someone what do you mean
she slid into it
[Music]
that's a good question yeah it's just
it's like a slang swoop in
she knows him as a she knows she doesn't
know and she knows of him from the
bachelor so what does that have to do
with anything well she's basically using
her of having
uh her priorities not be the right place
she's basically saying yeah you weren't
ready to marry colton columbus looking
for a wife
you were looking to slide into this
other guy's dms
you're like
she's trying to she's trying to get hook
up with another famous guy yeah
basically saying you're trying to like
climb a fame ladder and like
dean
you imagine like saying like yeah like
the bachelor verse
he's such an unremarkable person to be
like
bachelor nation but now you know what
sliding the dms means
okay so
direct messages no but what's the
expression sliding into dms
no that's just
those are the specific dm's that she
slid into dms yeah what does that mean i
have enough values we just explained it
well just you can hook up with somebody
through internet
you send them a direct private message a
private message on their instagram like
i want you as a boyfriend
sure
you